what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder today
we have some very interesting news it's
some sad news but i also think that a
lot of people are taking this way out of
context ryan reynolds took to social
media yesterday and he announced that he
is taking a sabbatical from filmmaking
so everything that he's doing right now
currently is unfortunately on hold and
yes that does mean deadpool 3
unfortunately but there isn't much to
fear because ryan reynolds seemed to be
pretty clear on how long of a break he's
going to be taking and let's not forget
that he's not the only one involved with
deadpool 3. so i'll break down this
entire news in this video and explain
why there's not that much to worry about
but deadpool 3 is kind of on hold for a
little bit so if you want to stay up to
date on deadpool 3 and other mcu news be
sure to subscribe hit that notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos so his announcement came
yesterday from social media specifically
his instagram account yesterday he got
done filming spirited with will ferrell
a movie that he has with him coming out
soon and apparently according to himself
it's one of the most challenging films
that he's ever had to work on and he
said in his instagram post that's a wrap
for me on spirited not sure i'd have
been ready to say yes to a film this
challenging even three years ago which
i'm assuming he's referring to pre
pandemic and kids in school etc etc he
continues to say singing dancing and
playing in the sandbox with will ferrell
made a whole lot of dreams come true and
this is my second film with the great
octavia spencer and here's where he made
his announcement he said perfect time
for a little sabbatical from movie
making i'm gonna miss every second
working with this obscenely gifted group
of creators and artists these days
kindness matters as much as talent i've
been lucky to work with folks who are
flush with both now of course after he
said this everybody freaked out and when
oh my gosh deadpool 3 is cancelled or
it's going to be pushed back a year and
i definitely understand why everybody is
freaking out deadpool 3 is one of the
most anticipated marvel movies that is
up and coming it's personally on the top
of my list of movies that i really
really want to see especially since
deadpool is going to be in the mcu now
but fortunately for us there are two
reasons why we don't have to worry in
one is that ryan reynolds actually kind
of teased us a little bit and hinted at
how long his sabbatical is actually
going to be of course after the
bombardment of news everybody reporting
that he has taken a break from
filmmaking and deadpool 3 is delayed
everybody was wondering well how long
does a sabbatical last how long is ryan
reynolds going to be gone for and he
posted this to a story to kind of let
people know a little bit it says a
sabbatical can last anywhere from two
months to a year in general six months
is the standard length of time for a
paid sabbatical it gives you enough time
and flexibility to do things such as and
it originally said travel study or
complete a major side project but he
crossed that out and simply put parent
he wants to spend more time with his
kids devote more time to them which i
totally and completely understand making
a movie is very hard it takes a lot of
time away specifically from your family
and kids but fortunately for us the
definition that he posted onto his
instagram story says that it's going to
be anywhere from two months to a year
with the standard being six months so it
doesn't look like he's going to be gone
for very long at the most a year so
we're really looking at at the worst
case scenario a year delay which
probably won't happen if there is gonna
be a delay it's probably only going to
be six months because here's the second
reason we don't have to worry that much
ryan reynolds is not the only person
working on deadpool 3. yes he is helping
write it yes he is deadpool and the star
of the film however it is still in
pre-production they are still writing
the story then they have to cast and do
a lot of things before they actually
start filming and ryan reynolds wasn't
the only writer they actually hired the
mollino sisters to write deadpool 3 with
ryan reynolds writing as well so they're
still working on the film so production
for the film really isn't being delayed
because ryan reynolds is taking a
sabbatical from movie making it
obviously is going to affect it a little
bit but there's a lot that goes into
this stuff just think of the credits for
movies at the end there are so many
people and teams involved so ryan is
taking a sabbatical which is great for
him i hope he spends a lot of time with
his kids i hope he enjoys it and at the
same time deadpool 3 is still being
worked on of course ryan reynolds will
come back and put his input on it and
maybe it will be delayed just a little
bit maybe six months but luckily not too
much longer because remember kevin feige
said they already have a date for
deadpool 3 set we don't know what it is
but he did say they have it set so don't
worry too much about deadpool 3 it's
going to be coming pretty much when it's
supposed to if not just a tiny bit later
like i said if you want to stay up to
date on deadpool 3 in all mcu news be
sure to subscribe don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof